it was quite the haul for a group of  armed robbers who got away with more  than their weight in gold after a heist  in Brazil surveillance video shows men  with masks disguised as police officers  drive into part of an airport in South  hallow their pickup truck looked like a  Brazilian federal police vehicle they  forced workers to load more than 1,600  pounds of gold into the truck before  making their getaway authorities say two  airport workers were taken hostage  during high snow was hurt 40 million  dollars in gold this is a movie I was  smiling at the start I shouldn't have  been it's just it's a movie it's a movie  fact that these guys are still at large  - I mean they're really at large this is  our go plan very well planned